and welcome to this broadcast I hope I'm
live
it's always a little bit difficult to
tell ya they give you this message that
your life but until you're really on the
screen hmm I tend to wait for some
response in the chat yeah I'm sorry
about the announcement that I posted on
my own YouTube channel ik totally
confused things and I got the wrong time
in the in the title that was on the
video then the audio was right Ike
recorded it today and then you that I'm
starting at 10:00 10:00 in the evening
European time but for some reason I took
the wrong template and had the wrong
time there yeah it is usually is at that
time yeah 10 o'clock
German time or Central European Time
okay one thing that I need to say right
away there won't be a show next week
because I'm away on a tournament but for
the moment let's have fun one hour of
chess okay is there something cool to
watch let's start with that I don't see
any super great game no not really
so you have to bear with me I'm going to
make some attempts that chess myself
let's see
crazy gambits hmm crazy gambits are
requested I can try I'm not so great
about that was kind of things but I can
try I requested a five-minute game
playing against iron mu yeah I can if
you want the gambit I hope I will start
with e5 and see if I can get the
Schliemann gambit yeah here we go
that is a gambit f5 well it is a gambit
but very often white is declining it so
it happened here let's see yeah I'm not
really yeah well this is this is a good
good
for me then I'm able to pin the might hi
my tonight yeah feelin alright had a
very nice week of vacation last week
been to the very air had a good time
relaxing a lot next week I will be away
again but this time for a very serious
chess tournament so this is serve the
next week will be a fun I hope but it's
also a little bit of work did I know
that there is a select castle in ponent
no I did not know that I know that there
is a town of the name on a village of
something so there might as well be a
castle um there are many many questions
what car am i driving I'm driving a Mini
Cooper S so the sports version of the
mini it's the MINI Countryman a little
bit bigger Mini so it's not that many
but yeah I love to love that car it's a
great car to drive much fun ok so what
is this he's going for night 2 is 6
hmm bit awkward
that's a bit awkward but 96 I mean I
have visual 7 this possible pin nice he
wants to play a six himself I have to
prevent that yeah but now age six
I mean nighty six looks like it's not
returning yeah ninety-six Bishop a seven
night f8 I don't know but I can't move
the rope and then play Bishop f7 next it
looks like this thing is not not going
away yeah this is no I can just take him
96 was just just not good and this is
terrible yeah I get Queen takes h3 going
yeah this is something that you don't
get in the people in the slow rule
oppressed loins this kind of quick
attacking games and here after night you
form it's it's really curtains Queen
edge to a checkmate so much so much for
a gambit so we've got a win quick window
at the Schliemann gambit okay let's get
a new game yeah you want gambits if if I
once twon't okay then I have to play you
for I with white
yeah someone's girlfriend drives a mini
yeah it's it's a great car I really like
it a lot
yeah I'm going to play a tournament a
grandmaster a closer
Grand Master event played in Majorca so
I'm I'm I'm pretty excited about that
interesting interesting will be
interesting to do playing in a very
close tournament okay it's playing a
funny sideline here with d3 and so on
against the Schliemann yeah that's not
that's not very exciting the line that
he chose but it's very healthy not
easily irrefutable or anything I'm just
playing
normal moves and then see what happens
okay long castles yeah I mean I'm glad
to have it closed here the center and
then I'm trying to get to with b5 get
get going with B 595 interesting no I
don't want to trade I want to kick him
back with c6 and then play b5 it's not a
good idea
interesting okay let's send this back
and then Knight to d4 yeah this is where
we want to be maybe here and then right
FA to e6
maybe night h4 f 5 is a plan but I'm
quick quick on G form yeah playing
quickly
I mean don't know if he can avoid that
now he cannot but this is now nice young
both captures are nice
okay so b5 him opening up opening up the
position while he's got misplaced
misplaced pieces I don't I don't think
that Jakob heym do display he already
has the GM title on doesn't he so
probably he won't play em player GM
tournament yeah I'm taking at a moment
where Luke takes this answered with
Bishop age three and I'm just opening up
opening up his position here Jake's and
there should be six using this hanging
c4 pony let's see how do I get more
pressure there rook f8 probably no the
Grandmaster and German this is the GU
horse my style there are people people
tell me that they're like the sound of
go horse Meister but I like them the
grandma Esther oh I'm probably
butchering the pronunciation but the
Spanish girl on my Astro I really like
the sound of it okay this is a nice
position how do I get this in the bag
now Bishop b3
for Queen C for trick I might still take
let's just take it for Quincy form oh I
didn't really think about that one very
simple reply
I was silly then this should be three
was a really really silly mom and more
City move I mean now this was bad just
losing lots of time for no particular
reason how do I enter his position here
maybe I have to do something like that
it doesn't look great but maybe I have
to yeah Queen after I don't like to
Crete rate but I don't I didn't see a
great alternative yeah I miss played
there
the question about the wing gambit of
the Sicilian yeah if you ask me why this
just upon down for nothing or very
little but I'm not not an expert you
might have some knowledge that I don't
have I really am cannot cannot tell you
more okay hmm takes the fatigues
for Luke g7
and wonder g6 is probably not a great
idea mmm we should do it for Luke g7 I
don't see a great movie 'm that didn't
that didn't really pan out well I had a
really nice position at one point but
then it really went downhill
yeah I have okay - maybe it's not that
bad
the connect system with a 4 a 5
interesting liner a very interesting
sideline by Withey 45 yeah but this is
this is again looking quite okay maybe I
have chances for Bishop III em okay yes
this night discoveries but I mean later
Bishop e2 is also move 92 okay I cannot
take because of because of night the
night move but I can attack before now
now it's again pretty pretty nice
actually for me do I have a better move
than I guess taking is okay the central
pawn is not bad okay yeah let's go back
to e2 and prepare you for
plain too slowly I'm playing too slowly
here not playing badly but just hit just
not quick enough can take here Oh
interesting
and this is nice for me I think because
of my active King
and it's a draw of course but he will
play on time for only yeah I wanted to
play a win on time [ __ ] against rook
yeah I mean I was just I was just too
slow and people people are not taking
draws in this positions they just want
to win on time okay next one next one
hora bets yeah they wanted to they want
gambit right so I'm going to start with
you for something something aggressive
maybe I can transpose to the Smith Morra
gambit yeah I'm insisting take the pawn
let's see if he can avoid it
Oh is some just giving it back I mean
that's a kind of weird yeah am i
planning more endgame in middle game
strategy yep
I'm planning more of those videos just
I'm just
I just had time problems yeah my my book
took off took up lots of time it is
finished now and now I've got this
tournament coming and so on so I will
have much more content on my youtube
channel starting about February 9th
February 10th when I'm back from from
the tournament
there will be more more things also I'm
there was a question what about the
viewer games yes you sent me tons of
games it's fantastic I have so much to
choose from many interesting games and
the the thing is you can send me you can
send me more of course and I'm glad to
do the analysis on the games there is no
particular thing that I prefer or like
to see more than others to send me your
games make sure to include as much
information as as possible
so that I know a little bit about the
players about you or the opponent and
the time control all these kind of
things
because it helps to understand better
the circumstances of the game and that
will post the first videos of those some
fewer games also when I'm back from this
this tournament so beginning of February
okay yeah it's it's a that's an
interesting position here I wonder if
this was right yeah why does a nice
position here but it wasn't clear how to
continue his Queen obvious six is a bit
awkward this is why I went 94
they didn't send me blitz game that's
really if you want to have my have me
analyze your game there should be at
least a rapid game yeah so that there is
some some kind of quality in it let's
say just I mean it's no use to not not
much used to look at a blitz games in
this in this context okay so we should
f4 here first maybe yeah this first and
then take on a5 and now maybe you can go
to the 7
hmm okay is it ticking you're taking
them f4 is hanging him this is not very
nice so Bishop Bishop to age 6 or is
this a bad idea
probably Israel let's just centralize
just centralize the PCM hmm
also keep some protection on c3 yeah I
was thinking d6 might be a move now yeah
come on I don't have tons of time
yeah d6 I just want to if he takes take
on f6 that really ruins the structure
completely not sure if this is that
brilliant for me but it looks tricky 95
is not possible because my Queen Hanks
but I was thinking a move like that
should be interesting Bishop c3 the
squeegee fire for the hanging rook and
if he goes Bishop somewhere to g7 I have
Queen g5 in the tempo and then 95
interesting and are planning to do any
non ICC live streams well okay I do live
streams for the eyes to see which are of
course on the ICC and maybe on my own
channel but not not much it's just not
such a great experience on other service
ok Queen g5 for the tempo and f6 I take
f5 for a great position yeah that looks
nice and I even have a big advantage on
the clock
whoo haha
I don't know how this happened but I
have a big time advantage so 95 yeah
this this move you want to play let's
see Knight f6 check King h8 and then
what now I have six blunders the Knights
okay so I shouldn't do that good that we
looked at it though so rook be one for
the tempo here rookie one it's the Queen
age for whom they're not really
yeah I mean he can play queen Android I
don't really know if it is doing much
good chickie I wonder if I'm overlooking
some some tactic here it looks like
there could be a tactic I don't see it I
don't see it so let's just play this
pollution I'm a pawn down but it is
still dangerous that was a bit hard to
believe
because he treats one of his active
pieces really with the Queen tough yeah
I could take on g7 but it's it really
wasn't bleeding too much 97 Queen g7
just the trade yeah yeah I saw the
tactic that you guys mentioned but he
didn't lead to much at least I didn't
see it
okay look look h4 that looks nice but
it's not doing much
he's got Queenie fire
try to get f7 won't get pawns back and
threatening Bishop e5
for night is seven maybe night is seven
and I won't I really want Knight a5 to
happen so I'm regrouping
yeah maybe maybe something like that
it's still quite nice for white can win
this pawn yeah I saw that I'm losing
losing this pawn I was thinking that
this is maybe a dangerous attack no
that's no maid ah it's so I thought that
is a maid actually no I lost some time
huh whoa gap ah what do you know I play
without sewing that this is irritating
me okay next one I shouldn't lose on
time again this was bad that was really
bad
poor okay I will see I have no time
warning I'm playing without sound I
guess I should unmute maybe but it's
irritating in the live stream ah I'm
time to say I'm a bit slow without the
sound I think it costs a little bit a
little bit of time our penguin our
penguin let's see yeah I played him
recently
let's see Kings gambit Kings Indian
sorry I know this line yeah let's play
the funky h4 line against the grid rod
always leads to too funny positions yeah
as you see has no one ICC has no a pool
with increment it's been a subject of
discussion with the ICC officials but
they don't want to introduce one it
seems it's simply not something that
they want for reasons I am not complying
with but
what can you do I have to bear with the
time losses okay so this is a strange
line the h4 line of the green thought
but I try to make something happen here
oh that's interesting
he wants to get rid of this year
immediately huh
okay so let's provoke e6 that is
certainly useful to provoke I wonder if
check is netting me anything probably
not
I don't eat Ben & Jerry's really okay
okay so we have a relatively slow
position here he with age six he has
clarified the situation on the edge file
it's quite funny on the queenside looks
like a normal position and yeah I turn
off this sound normally because it's
irritating in the video sometimes so I
have it turned off here I think from
last livestream that I did but um
yeah Sandra that's great to hear do that
if the three to pool would be like
Christmas that's a question can I
recommend good books that focus on
improving the middle game yeah the
middle game is very difficult
simply it's it's such a wide range of
things and there are some a book I'd
like which is some which is good form a
pretty wide skill level is a book by
Dutch I am Hellman fund Groton now
hammer growth and sorry it's not then
gluten sorry for that it's a chess
strategy for the club player or
something like that this should be the
title i have the german toddler guten is
the name it's a very very nice book and
what i what i wouldn't yeah what I
wouldn't choose us
most of the stuff by what what marked
varetsky is doing these books are
excellent but they're simply too
difficult I mean they're difficult for
me so well you know so I feel it's not a
good idea for let's say Club players to
to study them it's also good to study
tactics once in a while I see a tactic
as well like that one winning the Queen
yeah this b6 move was a bit weird it's
decision they're so high just one chess
strategy for club players that's
probably probably the title so yeah this
is a good thing a good book that I liked
for for normal players let's say you're
1,700 want to improve 1800 this is the
kind of book that definitely helps you
form for even stronger players there are
some things by drugs by turetsky
Jakob Jakob are gone
the Danish Scotch I am is very good
stuff who I wanted to play a gambit but
now it's not candy I can try the
Marshall gambit but this is kind of
funny because they have no idea do I get
it on the board
no I don't ok so he played one of the
various and time Marshalls
is that a move I don't know there is
this kind of idea and then play see five
let's do it
Oh God is a GM I did say I am sorry yeah
sorry I meant no nothing bad with that
I'm sorry yeah of course he's a GM very
and very good author he's authored many
of many very good books ok hmm don't
like my position that much it some
things something's a bit off here what
did I do wrong
ok I can take on age six Bishop h6 boom
yeah a little bit
I looked a little bit too much it to
chat yeah I think Bishop takes age six
wha
yuck okay um how do I try to defend
against that come on c4 maybe it does
look it does look really terrible
okay let's take now but you know this
sucks big time
it's just losing I think he's taking
their yeah why not
night two age six yeah it just lost this
position not sure if he played it in the
best possible way but it still looks
pretty terrible
I have no King position absolutely no
King position and move like Queen d2 is
probably already very problematic Queen
eight six that's a question dear do I
think
Carlton's performance has dropped last
year no not really
there is no no big difference what a
position maybe I can can exchange and
maybe I can trade Queen Sam I really
don't think I mean he he wondered the
rapid and blitzberg blitzberg
Championships father for the Triple
Crown if this is a name and he won the
World Championship match ultimately
rather convincingly so I think he's okay
with what he did last year
okay 98 or something I have no other
square there is no particular way to
play of solid or tactical decision you
if you want to be the player who's
stronger than you on paper you just have
to play a normal game that
the best way to do it just play what you
what you are able to do well so you
should just play according to your
strengths and not to the other guy okay
I can take here I mean I don't think I
don't really claim that my position is
great but it was worse far worse I mean
here I'm always I'm almost having some
hope that I can sacrifice on f2 or
something huh yeah I will play games
with viewers if they challenge me of
course
I mean isn't this winning this looks
looks winning 94 King takes not G for
check this this should win everything
anything else would surprise me I didn't
calculate I must be honest with you this
is just the thing that should win so I
went for it okay he didn't take probably
a wise decision what now yeah well I
cannot I can't take on e4 but this goes
as Queen g8 which is really annoying
move maybe here okay rook t6 I've got
Queen e2 at least
intending bishop g3 or Knight g4 but
then then again the Queen okay g3 and
Queen e2 yeah how do i how do I finish
this here maybe I can take you can take
on a form hmm that's not so great and
Queen g5
we're poor that's not great I cannot
move the night now that's bad that's bad
and now we can take on f4 in print 5
which should secure Maduro I think maybe
now yes to take a fall when I play the
Bavarian open again probably yep
very nice tournament
you can match me rated or unrated I
really don't mind the the the rated
thing is it's the Blitz rating which I
don't really care about I mean the
five-minute rating is not very important
but at least this is what I see all the
time when I play in the pool and what is
this guy doing no move or did I overlook
something and he wants to make fun of me
he can just take them and Queen g5 yeah
this is probably the draw and it not
much to do you have spoiled a win in
this game but not good okay so a new
game coup Rumania Rumania from Namibia
who is this guy
Gil Podolski G m25 something okay
so let's bring them more a gambit upon
you let's see 9 he declines it
hmm I don't know that line which is no
one that I really have no idea about the
about the c3 so in which we now have
yeah play the Glick system he have two
people have to play e4 e5 in the first
place um Bishop g4 and it looks like a
pretty meek iqp position but it's okay I
have a pretty healthy development okay
let's see if I can get some activity on
b7 and the knight down okay that's
interesting if I take there you take
with the I am I see okay if I play
Bishop takes Knight e4 okay
yeah that's it's okay if I'm
okay Bishop III night a exam that's a
bit annoying here this thing maybe I
should play this move it looks strange
but it intends Bishop III and then he
has no no piece to dig mm 23 maybe yeah
I know I cannot take because of 93 and
this looks shaky Quincy 3 looks shaky
now let's just return this this Queen g3
look shaky rook c8 for rooks III and 92
and so on
yeah black should be better I understand
your idea but it's not so not so clear I
asked him if he just wants to repeat
yeah he does not want to repeat so let's
develop further
hmm okay yeah a 3/4 night b3 not a good
idea yeah I cannot develop my my bishop
'i'm so easily makes the position
difficult to play okay maybe i can
irritate him a little bit
h4 h5 hmm I don't know it doesn't look
very dangerous there's a question how do
you feel about playing the English the
English with wide or the English defense
both okay interesting I have not read
all the books they are all chassis
mm-hmm
they are watches I basically sold all my
non chess books from while ago we're not
not like this is not like a big
statement or anything it was just
cluttering my whole place I mean I had
like hundreds of books and I just
decided that okay I'm not going to read
this novel again and I just I just
decided to do to sell them okay
hmm okay yeah 95 is coming we're just
kind of kind of annoying all that moves
you know I can play Queen before I get I
get some I know I only get two pieces
hmm oh I really played a bad game yet I
have to sacrifice the Queen other other
moves are really I mean this is losing
but if the other moves are even worse so
I had to had to go for that maybe I can
irritate him a little bit here with with
Knight and with the knight only six that
was really a bad game f3 is also falling
yeah that looks awful but I have to
cover up three at least for a moment
yeah and here I thought maybe at least
of his weakened himself but my f3s s
lost yeah that was a bad game really
really really bad game yeah there are
some magazines yeah there are some
magazines I mean it's not like that's
everything that's a little bit more on
this side okay so let's let's start with
a new game that was really really bad
haha yeah sometimes yeah only I already
donated like 200 books to my chess club
if you if you buy a chess books for for
20-something years I'm not open for
matches that's bad I don't know
I think I should be able to take
challenges now okay um I really want to
win this game that that last loss was
kind of frustrating for the baden-baden
tournament not sure when this starts
it's an interesting event so maybe I
cover it okay it's possible that that
I'm still playing my this tournament and
so I cannot I cannot cover the
tournament I only I only speak English
and German and yeah I understand a bit
of Dutch but really I cannot speak the
language and well I can order a coffee
in Spanish these kind of things with
this very very little okay
I don't like my position here then
teachers reminds me of the dentist
doesn't doesn't really sound friendly
and yeah not a very nice position let's
see
do I think there are openings that under
two thousand players shouldn't play hmm
well nothing in particular
I mean on on somewhat on somewhat lower
levels some people sometimes believe
they should play em should play
sidelines a lot somehow to avoid theory
or whatever I don't know it is very
often a good idea to just play normal
healthy moves even some main lines why
not
they are main lines for a reason and
just make sure that you get a healthy
position and if you feel that you get
healthy positions out of the opening so
something where you're not substantially
worse or feel very uncomfortable with
then it's okay and study on other things
and focus on other things look at middle
games look at end games look at plans
their plans for your opening so they're
very often they learn on lines and but
they don't know how to continue yeah
they'll just start and then they're all
of a sudden have to play em have to play
a middle game and wonder okay what what
exactly am I doing here
so this is often the problem people
learn openings but they don't really
learn the ideas behind them you know
they just put out some moves and then
wonder what happens next and this is
where the improvement starts you have to
look at the common positions the ideas
what kind of plans are happening and
this is where you can really gain
playing strengths not with yeah learning
some some line by heart okay this guy is
playing on the queenside like this no
tomorrow but there is also a king in
chess and I have some pieces near it
let's see hmm
maybe just this form rook h8 probably
meet the rook how do I do that nighty
for my sister no I guess it's a fork and
she cannot take it
taking it opens up the light squares in
a deadly fashion really so the Queen has
to move and that's not very nice
I'm really just Queen c7 now next smooth
and look set up some looks nice
let's see hmm
rook h8 maybe and now that you cannot
play rook h1 look h1 I can take and take
g3 was Czech yeah people very often get
get caught up with studying some
openings and it just eats up time and
they never get anywhere they also tend
to buy books that are far too far too
complicated for their level
I see people buying those Grand Master
repertoire books with ratings of 1600
1700 it's it's as useless people cannot
they cannot memorize this this this
books these books there they're just too
complicated I have given up on those
books because and I have a really
excellent memory it just it just too
much and especially those some kind of
club players they they have other other
things to worry about in chess then
gender learning and opening by heart
okay so I can give the check now on a
tree which looks kind of dangerous if I
take his cut d5 chick so I'm starting
with this king of three - gee
checkmate so not a move and here maybe
it wasn't a great idea now that I think
of it
that isn't that isn't so clear all of it
petechia is got the check
d5 check and i really don't have good
squares taking one g3 assassins starting
with that probably not yeah i probably
have to do that
this is move this looks wacky but I have
to play that move it was a check yeah I
ever took on g3 Knight takes I don't
know what what what what is the
continuation this looks ok he has to do
now g2 and now just rook f8 looks good
for Bishop Bishop takes d5 he doesn't
have a king really Knight also has
pinned so that looks like winning huh
weird game but at least to win its
quality chess just trying to make a lot
of money no the GM reporter books they
are fantastic there they have a
fantastic level but I mean there are
really four super strong players
I mean players of like say my strengths
a little bit lower maybe like freedom
masters or so but I mean it's not like
it is they're useless for weaker players
but it's it's just like it eats up I
mean ages of time to look through all
this stuff and really the the typical
Club player has other things that she
should improve yeah people make tons of
mistakes and end games middle games
whatever and take me a viewer challenge
from up-and-comer so here we go
I'm playing e4 yeah I don't get the Glac
system they play don't play d5 ok let's
play 5
[Music]
there are some question if if I like the
the tiga boomer higher this is a series
of books by our two Yusupov and this is
an English version boost your chess and
build up your chairs and so on there are
really good yeah they are really good
for players let's say starting thirteen
fourteen hundred improving from them and
it goes to a very very decent level I
really recommend the books a lot I have
three of watch chess sets but nothing
nothing nothing fancy huh something like
that it's um I mean I do most of the
work on them on the computer anyway so
it's not that I'm doing much um the
board I never play the Scotch opening
that's possible I never thought about it
not I don't think it's bad but I mean I
mostly play play the Roy or sometimes
the tying game when I play you form
which is seldom enough mmm my book
doesn't cover every line in the limbs oh
it covers a repertoire for black so I
have I'm sorry I have covered one or two
lines against everything so not all
possible lines which is difficult anyway
nowadays because there are so many so
many lines to to look at yeah in this
game here by the way um I just won the
pawn on c5 and I'm not quite sure if
he's going to get it back hmm maybe I
had something stronger but this looks
good 94 is a pretty pretty big big idea
I probably won't make cattle steal
videos because I'm only the thing is I'm
today I'm at home for three days and I'm
then I'm going to this tournament I
simply don't have time to do it okay
what I'm doing here is I'm losing lots
of time and I have a bad feeling about
it hmm
I shouldn't have played this this in
this particular way I guess he's got
some some good activity now I was
planning to to do this but he maybe has
deform or the CAPTCHA on f1 yeah this a
question people have problems adjusting
to an actual chess board when you start
with online stuff yeah that sets a
problem but there is no particular tip
just try to use the board once in a
while the real board I have the same
issue I'm working on a two-dimensional
born on the screen all the time and I
always have a adjustment time that I
need hmm when I to get used to a real
board it doesn't happen that much in in
tournament chess a long time control
chess I mean but in blitz I have
problems with there
against III in the nihms or after the
Huebner variation and some other lines
the Huebner against 93 okay so I'm going
to grab this was chick and then take F
form I wonder with the bishop yeah maybe
with the quit the Queen just playing for
the for the bishop am we just still have
I belong that i blundered some some some
porn back but it's still nice no I won't
play the Reykjavik open this is just too
much playing all those tournaments it's
nice to do and I would love to pee
wizard Iceland but I have to earn some
money once in a while spending it on
tournaments this is fun but it's it has
some limits I really want to get my my
teaching going yeah I love to play with
those bishops
it's nice and he's spending lots of time
[Music]
so rookie one I guess just activating
trying to get rid of this active rook
let's see I hit this trade though I'm
threatening Bishop c6
and now is there something I can do b5
winning this the book will probably be
out in April okay I'm going to check
here
yeah it is finished I mean the writing
of the book is finished but there are
still things that the the publisher has
to do I mean besides the simple process
of printing but they have to all can do
all kinds of things do a cover and and
and things so it will take a while
before I started to do a chest full time
I was working in a bank doing finance
and controlling things yeah basically
counting spent money on i.t i.t
controlling it was there's a question
we'll have write another book hmm
yeah I am Not sure it is it is fun to do
in a way but it's a long process and
it's nothing that is very rewarding
financially so it has to be considered
carefully do you want to spend lots of
time on something that is somewhat
questionable in terms of financial
reward it depends on the on the sales a
little bit yeah everyone challenged
opened by sunny 2000 so I know it's not
very high rated but he challenged me so
I'm going to going to to take this
challenge
we get the glick system ok I'm going to
play this funny move yeah please don't
imitate that if you don't know what it
what it means it's a funny gambit that
is better than it looks it's quite funny
it's a helloween gambit reversed
my favorite over the board intimidation
tactic I don't have one I'm really not
much of over I don't know I really don't
think much about those things I want to
play good moves and normally it's it's a
good recipe okay the night hangs and I
don't know how it's going to protect it
it looks a bit problematic III is also
in the mix okay g6 okay
yeah I wonder Queen g5 Bishop g7 isn't
this just losing the knight to f6 Bishop
e7 Queen f4 still somehow holding on d4
than f6
did I encounter interesting emit
intimidation tactics and Tony's
interesting I don't know I once I once
played in a tournament in the mid 90s
been been a while played in 18 year old
yes girl the right 18 year old yeah
woman girl from from Poland and she was
very attractive and she won the the Miss
Poland beauty contest one or two years
later I don't say it was intimidating
but it was irritating definitely that
was really irritating and she doesn't
play anymore and I forgot the name to be
honest so you cannot look her up I think
so this looks looks really nice and this
queen is it's not having many square I
have Queen edge who yeah Queen a - looks
nice
by the way I lost I lost the game
against this girl from a very nice
position
that's a funny question if I would
rather save my camera on my arch-nemesis
would a gas from from falling down it's
only cliff yeah obviously Nakamura funny
okay this this looks like queen bee one
mate I got a very nice position yeah
that said sounds kind of weird
okay we're already 10 minutes 10 minutes
above time and I got I got some some
challenges
is there someone challenging me from the
chadman up monkey I take this one
challenge to take this from the chat
just one game and then I have to have to
quit it's um I really have to say I
really have to stop after one hour the
thing is that I see CSM is needs to
money to all the Chad and so on I just
cannot do it for for ages so just just
one more game and at one point I have to
hit hit take take they go to sleep you
know okay be sure to before that was
that was that is nice to get in let's
trade here and Castle short
yeah this is a nice pin on the night
would be great if I can get him to get
this double pond installed I had a very
similar position in an earlier 5-minute
game
do I hear songs while playing chess
normally I mean no I mean this kind of
thing when you have a song in your head
and you cannot get rid of this yeah yeah
it can be very irritating it it was very
very irritating I had it with a couple
of songs but I cannot recall exactly
what it was it wasn't one very very
terrible German song that I couldn't get
out of my head
terrible really terrible okay what is
happening here he's defending quite
solidly how to play that my knight on c6
if you really don't know what to do it's
often a good idea to improve your worst
piece and my knight on c6 is not doing
anything yeah he maybe wants to exchange
it I'm getting it I know
yeah not healing official in official
please German singer now not Snoopy no
no this the German song that I couldn't
get out of my head was from Gil Johan he
participated in the European Song
Contest gildo Han maybe people remember
this from the mid-90s it was a terrible
song but I couldn't get out of my head
and somehow I think I drew this game
which was was very difficult
okay I'm getting my knight into the game
here
okay took on your six but now this is a
really awkward situation
I wonder if I take and place the night
okay let's take and then 9:27 it's a
very nice structure that I have yeah I
have a really nice pawn structure a 44
they're all weak and the bishop on g3 is
bad do I listen to Rammstein not really
I think they are okay but it's not what
I usually listen to don't listen I mean
I like metal but don't don't really
listen to that kind of music anymore not
that I have anything against it but it's
not not really on my higher my agenda
the best German band I think is some
that in that sings in German is this
element of crime if you understand
German you should check out element of
crime it's it's weird that they have an
English sounding band name but they are
they sing in German oh he just gave me
the Queen it was like this was a mouse
slip it wasn't Muslim yeah I resigned I
would have taken I would have accepted
the tape back but okay yeah so we have
to we have to wrap it up here already
like 13 minutes over them over the time
yeah I hope you enjoyed the stream got
some games in some viewer challenges I
didn't really play that well but I hope
it was entertaining played a couple of
crazy crazy gambits yeah one thing I
need to say again I'm not on next week
because I'm on this tournament normally
it will always be Mondays at this time
the 10:10 p.m. German time but it might
happen that a meal or whatever but I
will post this notices on my channel
also consider if you have Twitter if you
just how is it called
hallo follow the internet Chess Club on
Twitter they will always tweet those
kind of dates and times when when I'm
online or other people are online so
there are also other streams that Isis
is doing maybe with Joe Benjamin John
federal Ravitch whatever and they also
tweet this so if you have Twitter
considered to to follow the ICC
so you get notices ok I hope you enjoyed
it I'll wrap it up and well have a good
day or good night and depending on your
your time zone bye